[Music]
whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up drug
warriors from Connecticut to Oklahoma
who are hyping fears about digital drugs
kids need to experience these digital
drugs are headphones they're computer
and an mp3 player in Britain's National
Health Service for fighting obesity with
the talking plate called man Demeter
welcome Logan the device alerts eaters
if they're scarfing down too much grub
or eating too fast
Monda meat attracts the speed you are
eating at relative to what is
appropriate but there's only one nanny
of the month and this time it's Michigan
State senator Roger Khan for sponsoring
a so-called hot fur teacher bill she's
one in a string of young female teachers
who've admitted having sex with underage
male students it's not necessarily aimed
at those female teacher male student sex
scandals but it would make them felonies
even if they're consensual and even if
students are old enough to vote or go to
war
the bill comes on the heels of the case
where male teacher reportedly had sex
with a female student shortly after she
turned 18 Khan's bill would make it a
felony punishable by up to 15 years in
prison for teachers or most any school
employee or volunteer to have sex with
students even if the students are 18 or
older the bill would extend to adult
education teachers who could potentially
be younger than their students check
back next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your own business
you